if you're watching this I am no longer
here I'm on my way down to South
Carolina oh okay yes it is the beginning
of shindig Oh week on starting in like
ten minutes after this is recorded I am
going to be jotting down to South
Carolina so that I can spend off full
week making awesome videos with cyndago
if you don't know who cyndago is check
the description you probably know who
they are and if you haven't already
subscribed to them because you're
awesome and you will start to see some
amazing videos crop up on their channel
while I'm down there but worry not for I
will have my own videos while I am away
because I have scheduled quite a few now
I couldn't get a whole week's worth of
videos up in time so at a few days there
will be only one video per day maybe
I'll be able to figure out some time
because I am bringing my computer down
with me which is like a gigantic case
it's a full tower case and and stuff
like that so it'll be a long trek to get
that down there but once I get set up
down there with my computer hopefully I
will be able to record some more videos
for you so stick around my channel will
not be empty you will not be lacking for
markiplier I know how much you love me
and love my videos so do not worry so
thank you everybody so much keep an eye
out on cyndago channel you can check the
description for the link for videos that
are going to be cropping up any day now
you never know when there's gonna be
another one because we're just gonna be
hitting the ground running and making as
many as we can as fast as we can so
thank you again everybody for watching
click to the description to go over to
cinder gos channel and thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video